si aujourd'hui on est confiné si
aujourd'hui il ya des transports de
malades depuis l'est de la france vers
l'ouest de la france si la seine saint
denis
notre département est le département qui
a connu le plus fort taux de mortalité
lié à la crise du coc vide c'est par
manque de lits d'hospitalisation
[Musique]
l'ap-hp continue sur l'idée de le
supprimer l'hôpital bichat du premier
l'hôpital beaujon et de faire un nouvel
hôpital qui regrouperait les deux et au
passage où il aurait 300 suppressions de
lits
nous on pense que ce projet est tout à
fait inacceptable
[Musique]
et la spécificité de la
seine-saint-denis sait aussi que c'est
un département très jeune mais qui a
aussi qui concentre le plus de
difficultés sociales
il ya beaucoup de familles en difficulté
il ya beaucoup de familles qui vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté
il ya beaucoup de migrants qui arrivent
sur notre territoire et qui ont besoin
de soins spécifiques donc réduire les
capacités de l'hôpital public ne tient
absolument pas la route et ne tient pas
compte ni des besoins de la population
ni de l'avenir de ce territoire
[Musique]
où
c'est les politiques qui sont menées
depuis 20 ans autour de l'hôpital public
qui a tendance à réduire le nombre de
lits qui conduit à 7 à cette difficulté
est donc la crise de la copie de 19 à
accentuer le manque criant de lit et a
montré que l'idée de réduire le nombre
de lits dans les hôpitaux était une
aberration
[Musique]
une demande la rénovation et
l'agrandissement du chu à bichat claude
bernard sur l'emprise foncière de cet
hôpital
on demande la rénovation de l'hôpital
beaujon et on demande la construction
d'un nouvel hôpital mais un hôpital
supplémentaires en seine-saint-denis de
300 à 500 lits
m
[Musique]